hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm Amy castle Amy castles back baby we
are gonna watch a horror short film the
dollmaker presented by altar
I saw a horror film from them awhile ago
called the smiling man presented by
altar and it was great I think these are
different filmmakers I could be wrong
about that this is directed by ow I
don't want to read the plot description
I just want to see what this is about
real quick if you didn't see one of our
other videos
Amy castle for my birthday I made this
real rejects coaster and this real
rejects black plaque that's the word I
keep forgetting wooden plaque here you
guys got to go check out created by
castle that's me that's me I totally got
rekt created by God created by Castle
she can personalize stuff guys go check
out everything she's got to offer this
was one of the coolest birthday gifts I
could have ever gotten yeah why I love
doing it because it makes people feel
those it makes people feel good and
pressure to promote on their YouTube
channels so friendly you know what I'm
gonna change the lighting in here to
make it a little less bright oh right in
the camera yes lighting here but scared
already make it easier for us to enjoy
it oh you just said of clothes you wore
at least once do not wash them all also
need a lock of hair is Danny you be foam
it totally whatever [ __ ] as long as he
chairs the thing that's really work
nobody ever asked for their money back
well what the hell
[Music]
tell me what you think Tommy it's great
I
I think I think it's just a stick of dog
in overpriced stupid doll
don't be shy
[Music]
what
[Music]
go ahead buddy let's do whatever hi
skies
huh oh my god Wow
put that thing down Jenna let's take a
moment and think this world
[Music]
congratulations
got yourself a kid how did the
instruction manual
well as houses wasn't bright then I have
to spiritual not places chalkboard
energy this for myself
it's a weird inside your daughter's a
mess on the channel that energy but
outside
outside it's just a doll how Oh
wonderfully shot what do I feel like the
instruction manual comes with a long
list of warnings just one
do not spend longer than one turn the
hourglass with you ever one stands up he
must go back in the box for a whole day
before you take him out of here
what happens if I go overtime my
products like a drug money fund huge
dangerous to use ignore this rule
[Music]
after a responsibility Warren
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
why do you make the doll so creepy I was
just remembering when I said to you
after I told you that life can be a
cruel [ __ ] sometimes
that deep down we all have the strength
to get through whatever she throws us
and even if we should get that strength
it's always there
I said that I could be strong for the
both of us until you found your strength
again
so exactly that's [ __ ] Wow it turns
out that a week
and I made you responses you leave me no
we can either brave through this thing
together or let it tear us apart
what's a good BJ he needs to put that
thing back in the box
Oh holy [ __ ]
what a twist
[Music]
Wow I just want her back I need her back
I'll either set of clothes she wore at
least once do not wash them
I love to be the lock of hair
not a valuable possession of hers
that was very impressive yeah that was
very impressive holy crap Wow works for
adults too nobody ever asked for their
money back
Bravo yeah credible I am so impressed by
that the acting that which I was
especially impressed by I get a great
scene and just his whole process of his
feelings and that is so good they the
dad yeah the dad yeah I'm at twist
I was just let's change the settings
back you better you can't lighting idea
much better you look much better okay
hated the way you looked before wasn't
now you look better that was
exceptionally impressive oh yeah that's
the thing you like to digest before you
start talking about it really quick I
like horror stories of deal with grief
quite a bit it's pretty common
especially like indecent know an indie
horror cinema I notice they deal a lot
with grief things like babadook
hereditary you know whatever I think
it's such a great concept and since you
got the theme to explore with horror
because we can all relate to grieving
and how grieving can bring out a
desperation for us to regain what we
lost yeah this really plays into that
obviously because of the loss of their
son here everything about this little
horror short was perfectly realized yeah
from the family dynamics starting off
the husband as a guy who's like cynical
doesn't believe is you know big this is
dangerous and it's a warning the
desperate mom element to it setting up
the rules and then of course it's twist
revealed I didn't see it coming like no
I mean he's looking at her funny and
he's got the doll it's like hey like
me down a totally different path I was
like oops nope yeah it was amazed I
missed all of that I thought they were
gonna hold on now the lighting is better
[Music]
close you're going down one road and
then right at the last second they just
pulley on over to this other one I was
so into the drama of it and I was afraid
like what's he gonna do to her or I was
trying to think of what the boys is
gonna end it yeah is she gonna go
completely crazy go completely mad and
then kill him instead because she
refuses to let her son go like that's
the route I thought it was going yeah
that twist moment I don't think you
expect a twist to happen no like in that
moment specifically with this doll maker
the rules established for it are like a
little bit complex but you got enough of
what you needed to really pick up oh
yeah the actor I thought the way they
wrote his character is really cool
because he's not all about the mysticism
he's it's like he knew the mysticism is
just a part of his business so he's just
a business guy just like some conniving
graybeard
like an evil Dick Van Dyke kind of a
little bit yeah a little dark wonderment
I love that because this could have
easily been like a like ah just trying
to make a buck no this is what I do to
make a buck anything that goes wrong
that's on you but never ask for it once
you know and he knows they get addicted
to it it was scary and just so sad too
like I put myself in that person's
mindset of like oh my gosh I knew when
she said always we were you up with him
all night that she'd stopped using yeah
yeah
time turn I was like oh it's gonna go
down it is one of those films where it
impacts you and then it almost yeah you
need to take a minute because it kind of
it just hits you yeah because they from
they fulfilled every little gap that you
would have expected like with the piece
at the top of the rule of whatever that
what the hell those damn things say uh
hourglass hourglass or the rules of the
hourglass it's just crazy to think how
much this short film had me going yeah
when the dishes are all dirty and
everything like okay this is a good
visual storytelling like it's already
creepy enough when she's like what
funeral and then just top it off with
the next little bit and then he has the
arc of a dude who didn't want to
participate in this didn't believe in
this
the guy who ultimately descended into
the worst stage of it
poor guy you just feel sorry for him oh
and that's shot from when she goes
outside to right away back inside it was
very well at it the cinnamons the
cinematography combined with the editing
of it none of this was about like the
thrills and wasn't you like what makes
us carries that doll maker or the doll
it's all the psychology okay that's what
I thought was most impressive it's a
mood piece it's more about what happens
to the characters that makes it yeah and
they didn't go for like a big scare like
a boo or anything like that there's none
of that there's no jump scares and it's
like other than the one little more the
kid turns when he touches his kid's hand
it's like it's breaking that's like the
one like ha gotcha moment short that's
even sort of but the real terror was not
from the doll you know it was kind of
set up to be that that's why I thought
it was smart actually because I was
questioning likewise the toss it was
like scary like it because then you're
thinking the dogs gonna do something
with the moms gonna do so because the
dolls evil but it's not that it's just
how we use the doll which is sort of
playing like a metaphor he calls it it's
like a drug metaphor for how you use I
love this show that's other people that
was amazing I was really I was like oh
man I need I need a moment to gather my
thoughts
yes that's exciting when you find a
piece of film or short where it's doing
something different than you expected it
was going to so yeah props to them
coos everyone Walt loved the music too
as well yeah guys subscribe at altar
subscribe to the real rejects go pray at
the nearest altar and cookie
notification valve check out Amy on
social media go to cactus by Castle
created by castrated by castle I don't
know what will be on cactus by castle
that's special to me I'd like to wrap
this up with a patron in the day shout
out a person named Omar young Omar is a
young man recently married Congrats
him and his wife worked together a lot
both film enthusiasts both into
photography now that you are married I'm
assuming one day you will have a kid and
I'm advising you just based off the fact
that yet haven't messaged me in a while
the show
me a sign of neglect so I'm gonna say
that when you have a kid I would just
make the doll in advance just to be safe
you just want to be ready to go because
if you can't message me back and you
pledge to the channel it just tells me
that kids not in the best what happens
when you you don't matter I gotta I
gotta I gotta work off something and it
just becomes mean